Healthcare is a human right,
and we should all be able to access the healthcare that we need
in this climate. Especially
women should know that they have options to get the best
and most comprehensive healthcare available.
That's why I'm so excited to be partnering with Hey Jane,
the country's leading online clinic for women's
reproductive and sexual health.
Hey Jane offers safe, private,
and discreet services for everything from obtaining birth control
to abortion care,
treating UTIs or other vaginal conditions without judgment.
Hey Jane is currently available in 21 states,
and all of their medications are sent in discreet packaging
to ensure the privacy of their patients.
And is available if you live in a home,
a dorm, or PO Box.
But for those of us like me
who live in a stricter state like South Carolina,
hey Jane has a bunch of resources on their site to help guide you
both financially and logistically
to your nearest safe state.
So know that you have options.
Hey Jane has helped over 70,000 patients
and is committed to continuing to lead the charge
to ensure access to women's healthcare.
You're not alone. And women,
we tend to help each other
and we will continue to do so.
So please share this information with the women in your life
because it's so important for us
to know what options we still have access to.
And go check out all of Hey Jane's services on their website.